hey guys what's up this is andrew for
chances.com
so
what to say the situation is not great
guys let's go through what happened this
week
uh amcgme of course and i'm going to
discuss triple q spy and the major
indicators and i'm gonna give you my
view for the coming week let's get into
it
all right so let's start with amc
um
so what do we have here
pum pum
i did my last video last week guys and
i don't remember what i said but
probably that we arrived at a support
uh area
uh around 12.
so it was here third of june
on the 20-day moving average we went
slightly below
rebounded on this resistance that is now
support
and
we didn't manage to make this strong
move up
i was hoping for this if the rest of the
market was you know
bullish as well
amc hold pretty well yesterday minus 2.7
percent when the rest of the market lost
nasdaq three percent
sp why three percent 3.5 nasdaq so we're
going to go through that but i think
that amc holds pretty well but let's be
honest guys
it's not looking that good on the rest
of the market so i don't see how amc by
itself can really
you know uh rally
so the question is
rather to me uh
where could it go
if the rest of the market tanks because
it's looking like that to be honest
so
i would say the first support is once
again this trend line
so we have this yellow trend line with
the support around 11.7 but
it's not a strong one
so it might do something like this all
right this is the bullish case
um and the bearish case is that we break
that
probably find some resistance some
support on the blue
let's now support and probably go lower
so i think that we might go to nine if
the rest of the market thanks i think
that nine will be strong
i will personally buy some shares here
as i'm saying for the past months i said
that you know i don't increase my
position in amc
um because i don't have like strong
bullish signals and
nine is a good level for me to reload so
let's see this is the bearish case
okay
uh so let's see guys let's see what's
going to happen uh we can see that here
we have you know this kind of fake uh
fake signal that was here bullish
the volume was here are soluble 50 you
know and despite that bez took control
again so
uh in a bearish environment it's going
to be very difficult for amc or any
other stock to really moon you know even
if we have like one two three good days
then bears are going to arrive and just
bam smash it
so
we need the rest of the market to be
bullish and we're going to go through
that
it's not looking so good to me so jamie
jamie i lost some money here sorry for
those who followed my alert i mean it's
not lost yet but i bought a hundreds
naughty call
quite early it was not a good trade i
bought my call i think at 1 30 here i
was playing this retest
uh this
was here so it was yeah like 10 days ago
um
i had some hope here that we move and
complete the fifth wave 216 maybe go
through that
um
as you can see the fuse wave was
truncated i mean not really truncated
it's a fifth wave but a very small fifth
wave
and it's looks like this is complete
maybe not you know but i i don't see the
rest of the market being bullish the
coming week so
i don't see how gme can go to 160 but if
we have some bullish reactions maybe
early next week
um then jamie could you know complete
this fifth wave to 160 level which was
to me what was making the most sense
uh and then i think we need to again
take some energy i don't think the
whole market is ready to be bullish so
meme stocks won't
squeeze or rally strongly until we don't
have good signals so maybe september
something like that sorry for delaying
guys i mean i'm just analyzing the
situation
and the situation is here all right so
triple q guys i told you for a very very
long time since here guys that we're
probably going to go into 280 in june
okay
you can watch the videos i did you know
five months ago three months ago six
months ago i've been saying that for
quite some time i had a very decent show
position that helped me to
make some decent money here
um
and i took almost full profits now on
this position
um i was hoping here
we had a breakout recycle 50 we know you
have some we had some bullish reactions
we didn't have the volume once again
which is important for a strong reversal
to happen
um and we didn't have but we had the
volume on some stocks but not that many
so it was not looking so great but once
again as i had a short position i
personally took profit between 305 and
292 yesterday i bought yesterday guys i
bought this deep uh inflation i saw
inflation figures we can have a look at
that
uh they were not good
but um
8.6 i think against
8.3 expected
pam
so
of course it's a very bad signal sent to
the market it's what investors didn't
want to see and this is what we had i
still bought the dip because once again
this is a profit-taking situation and
before the end of the day i didn't know
we're gonna close at the at the low of
the day
which is bad with an increasing volume
so right now this is not looking good
i will probably try to reopen my short
position if we have a bounce so
i hope for a bounce because i have a
stop loss at 288
um
it's a trade i gave you guys so
i think the risk here is actually to gap
down all right
and not even being stopped
at 288 but at 280 or something like that
uh
i don't know what i'm going to do if we
gap down
on monday i'm probably going to reduce
50 at the open just in case we drop and
if we have a bounce i will take i will
reduce the rest of my position probably
higher so we'll average down the loss
uh and then i will find myself in a
situation like
probably most of you guys
with only my long position
because my short position is actually a
put spread so around 270 i'm losing all
of my short position it has been built
for this purpose because i don't really
believe we can go below 270. we could go
below 270 in the first
move down but right now as you can see
um we had here a nice
you know considered um
correction
on the upside because we are moving down
so the force wave here is a corrective
phase on the upside it happens in bare
markets all right corrective move
moves go up
and the scenario is very possible guys
the way we move here it's very the
volume increasing the gap down it's very
steep spo spy look at that guys papa
it's very steep it's cheaper than
everything we had before
and it based on macroeconomics figures
in a situation where we didn't want to
see these figures
so
i don't like it i don't like it
i will reopen my short position just in
case whenever i can on a probably on a
bounce
um
i hope for some good news maybe to
happen next week
i don't really see what could it could
be let's have a look so
next seven days what do we have
german inflation
non-event
ppi all right
producer data okay so it's less
important inflation but it's still
interesting oh all right fomc economic
projections fed interest rate decision
all right here we go guys june 15th
all right so everything is gonna be
played here
so june 15th guys i think that until
june 15th this momentum might
just
you know
increase
so maybe you move down
and then rebound
that that's a possible scenario as well
all right you know very short fifth swag
we go to 270.
okay so here is the deal
i see two scenarios from here it
either we bounce and then we move down
okay this is the bearish scenario all
right
and the bullish scenario is either way
guys
we go here and bam okay this is the
bullish case
so i see two scenarios in both cases
we're gonna go to 270. the question is
uh okay and the fed okay i didn't do
that perfectly but basically it's gonna
depend where is the fed
okay so you know the fed is going to
impact that if we have good fed
we probably going to bounce from 270
and if you have bad fed
speech and
interest rate decision
we're probably gonna dive to 230 and
then rebound so
how to play that
the way we move i think that right now
the best thing is to take protection
whenever it's possible
the thing is that now it's difficult
actually to get
really uh
you know a bullish signal that is making
sure that we are getting out of this i
mean if we go above 320 it would be
looking very good but
i mean
you don't want to take all of that in
your face right
so i'm not sure how to play that i'm
gonna think about it i'm gonna let you
know guys in my discord i need some time
but i see two scenarios
and in both cases i think we're gonna
drop more either monday other tuesday
wednesday but i think before the fed is
speaking we're gonna drop more
uh and then either we bounce on good
news or we dive on bad news all right so
spy not looking great so same thing
probably going to go to 370 and if 370
doesn't hold this is the good case
scenario 317 the bad case scenario is
like 3
50 something like that
340
probably
okay and this is the bad case scenario
guys
okay
the good thing is that once this would
have been done guys i think in september
we're gonna have a strong bull market
all right so we have maybe three more
months
in the worst case
of you know the market needs to purge
right to you know
uh
every
leverage investors needs to get
liquidated it's the way it works and
then we start from that again so there
are no more
over leveraged boos in the market and
so there is no one to sell on the way
down all right so this is what the
market needs to really
sustainably
reverse and be bullish
so this is the good news to me that
september should be good
bam bam bam u.s 10-year yield as you can
see guys so
we
we had some
relief here we went to 275 and the 50
day
which was not support so it was hard to
predict but acted as support here and
now we are moving higher and as you can
see on the weekly time frame
this is a typical
breakout retest and we go higher so i'm
afraid we're gonna keep going higher and
this is of course not good for the
market
dxy same thing
you can see the 50-day moving average
acted very well as support
so i had you know this kind of forecast
but
i didn't use it in my personal
investment you know that's the beauty of
technical analysis you can have good
predictions
and still not make the good trades and
sometimes you're gonna have bad
predictions but you're still gonna make
money in training we say better better
lucky than good
and here
uh whatever i didn't take the right
choices for me this week i lost some
money it's part of the game i'm still
very positive for the entire year so
let's
keep that in mind
and focus on what is coming
uh so 103
was resistance as you can see we went
through that we came back
and now we it looks like we're going
higher and this is once again in line
with what is happening on the equity
market last thing i wanted to check with
you guys the vix
27 boom all right
so
yeah
no big pattern here just up and down
basically
once again i checked the fix only for
one thing avix below 20 i knew we were
not below 20 of course but if we are not
far from that it's easier for bulls to
take back control avix below 20 is
bullish vixx above 20 is bearish i mean
it means there is risk and that a strong
move down can happen anytime or move up
by the way
uh so we want the vix to go below 20 for
bulls to take back control on the long
term all right here this is a bullish
period this was a fake out unfortunately
this was bullish all right every
uh long period of time with the wigs
below 20 is a bullish environment for
stocks all right keep that keep that in
mind
so that's it for today i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button so you're going to be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore see you guys